[Music]
my name is Mamoon [ __ ] allah i'm a
principal cloud architect with Accenture
I'm part of the Google center of
excellence within Accenture where our
mission is primarily to help clients
adopt the Google cloud and use the right
components and architect the right
solutions for them my partner for this
presentation apologizes and he had to be
at client settings so I would be doing
this session alone so before I go into
this session and talk about what we are
going to cover let me just do a quick
poll here how many in the session
migrated some of their data or all of
their data to Google cloud or any cloud
okay great about 20 people and how many
of those or others have applied machine
learning to that data okay whew
six seven of them okay great anybody not
interested in data okay good just
checking okay so in today's session
basically what I'm going to cover is
talk about some of the data migration
challenges that we see in the field we
talk to a lot of customers and every
customer situation is unique and every
customer brings to the table a set of
challenges that they may inherit or
encounter depending on their situation
and we have seen many of those so we
will be sharing some of those challenges
with you and talk about how we can
address these type of challenges so that
would be the first part of the
presentation and then we look into more
specific DCP type of constructs from
data perspective that would help as part
of the migration of your data from
unprimed type of situations or other
cloud providers to Google cloud platform
and then we'll look at some of the
architectures or best practices that
would lead you to get your data into GCP
and then talk briefly about machine
learning and some of the use cases for
machine learning and what can you do
about that right and then we'll all cap
it off with a client example
we have worked with to migrate their
existing on-prem Hadoop infrastructure
to Google cloud platform and talk about
some of the aspects of that example and
some of the lessons learned that we can
share with you and I'm sure a lot of you
probably are thinking or doing some of
that work as part of the process so
let's talk about the migration
challenges and before I get good get
into the challenges anybody knows what
that is swamp correct and the swampy
apicture is very expressing to some of
the challenges that we're seeing with
our customers I mean people started
looking into Hadoop probably around
2008-2009 and started migrating some of
their existing data to Hadoop and lots
of hype happened when it comes to Hadoop
and a lot of customers ended up with
lots of data being migrated to Hadoop
whether that's needed or not needed the
right solution or not it doesn't matter
in IT we look for these type of new
technologies and we start typing them
and suddenly we think that is the right
answer for many of the problems that we
have so a data Lake that's supposed to
be nice clear pristine that allows you
to get and gather the right insights
from the data that you have turns out to
be a the data swamp because of the fact
that the insight that was promised when
the data was started to be migrated is
not being fulfilled along with the fact
that the performance and the issues
around maintenance and the expenses that
are associated with data leaks are
spiraling out of control and that
basically puts a bucket of water if you
will called water on the whole process
and people start becoming less trusting
of this type of hype type of
technologies and impacts the whole
organization so this diagram basically
here shows a hard not necessarily a
broken one so in case you think that it
is the case so it's just a heart and
that hard to present the vitality of
your organization that vitality
basically comes from a variety of type
of factors you know you can look at your
infrastructure as one factor of that
vitality you can
look at your platforms that are based on
that type of infrastructure you can look
at your applications that are basically
being built on top of that what we're
seeing being built today these type of
things
they're great we can do a great job on
this type of systems but we're seeing
missing in the field that the data is
the missing link when it comes to these
type of systems we have data but we
don't have the right setup that the
right quality we cannot get the right
insights out of that data so that
becomes a challenge and that basically
contributes to the fact that you're not
realizing the full potential of the data
as part of the process
now some of these challenges that we
have when it comes to data and I think
probably all of you would relate to it
data silos anybody who has never
encountered any type of data silos
within the organization I would love to
meet them okay so data silos is a common
problem right so and even with Hadoop
when people started building data leaks
the premise was you have a data leak so
that you dump all the data is in one
single lake then what you can you go and
talk to customers you start looking at
okay somebody has a cloud error
somewhere they have map or somewhere
they have other type of distributions in
in data leaks and the question that
basically needs to be asked why is that
happening right and that's part of the
other symptom that we're having because
of the fact that the data is growing at
significant type of rate and that
significant type of rate basically is
forcing you to look at it and say well
there has to be something good out of it
and I need to store it somewhere and you
start adding and adding and adding and
that becomes a problem in itself right
and the questions that should have been
asked when you start adding this data
type of attributes and these data
volumes should have been asked in terms
of well is that the right data that I
need to look at it in the right format
are we going to use that data do I need
to go and store it in its existing
format or do I need to manipulate it
before I go and get it into my data leak
right these questions in many of our
customers where they have this type of
situations and
being asked and that's part of the
problem that's being manifested by the
fact that I have a data link but I'm not
fulfilling the promise of that data Lake
and can you please come and help us look
into what we can do about it right so
these are type of common challenges that
we see with our customers and many times
you know when customers start with these
type of things they start looking into a
PLC and a PLC type of setting everything
is great you take a simple use case you
create a PLC you run successfully with
it and you say ok well let's continue
with that that's not the right answer
right a PLC is a point in time small
snapshot that basically needs to be
taken with a grain of salt when you're
done with that PLC there has to be some
type of expansion into what does it mean
when it goes into production and what
type of extra additional steps that or
corners that you have cut in order to
make the timeline for that PLC and
achieve that success criteria that you
agreed upon before you started that PLC
right oftentimes you constrict the scope
so that you can do this in four weeks
six weeks everybody feels excited about
it then that continues to be part of the
organization and then that's where the
problem starts spiraling up and then the
fact that we have lots and lots of data
explosions and the fact that if you
looked at the database vendors five
seven years ago there used to be in the
typical four or five vendors and it was
a very easy selection between a and B
and C companies now if you look at the
diagram you probably see 50 60 70 type
of vendors everybody is vying for the
best in XYZ different type of structures
coming up lots of companies are
basically having issues and doubts
understanding well what does it mean to
be in this type of format or that type
of format right so that's part of what's
contributing to the mix as well and the
fact that we have lots of skills issues
that are hard basically for everybody to
keep up with because the change of the
technology is so significant and I'm
sure many of you and in this session are
suffering from that you just can't keep
up right you have to
be aware of lots of things in order to
keep up with the pace of change and if
that's part of your situation then it
becomes a problem for the organization
where you don't have the right skills to
make the right decisions and compound
that with the additional type of
different complex type of platforms
where you need to be in different type
of settings with hybrid different
platforms that makes it even harder so
these are some of the challenges that
we're seeing in the field and to look at
these challenges and not to do anything
about them would be something that would
set you up for even failure down the
road now what's our approach for data
migration in Accenture at general and
before I go and address the data
migration approach let me just talk
about three factors or reminders to
remind ourselves with before we get into
the approach the first one is remember
always the objective you know state the
objective and try to measure against
that objective that will help you down
the road when you assess whether what
you have done is correct or wrong right
if your objective was I am building this
project whether it's Hadoop
infrastructure on Prem or on cloud or
machine learning you name it my
objective is ABC and here's how am I
going to measure that objective and here
are the metrics that I'm going to
measure about because if you don't put
these type of things there is no
guarantee that when you finish at the
end of the day when the CIO or the CTO
comes to you and says how are we doing
on this well we didn't set an objective
therefore everything will go but if you
set certain objectives you have to
report against these type of objectives
and it keeps you honest as well as part
of the process so it's part of the
self-governance that you need to instill
as part of the organization and starts
with that and as part of the process you
know remember that we we want to derive
value out of data to enable ubiquitous
in type of intelligence what we call in
Accenture right different companies call
it different things but we want to have
that type of intelligence insights that
we want to bring to the table and we
want to make sure that we are bound by
these type of objectives and goals as
part of the process and as you go and
try to accomplish that type of objective
which is very noble one there are
different type of
companies we know that you know
different type of customers have
different type of settings and what's
appropriate for a small business may not
be appropriate for a large enterprise
right so you would have to take that
with you know my company five people
company ten people or a hundred or a
thousand or twenty thousand with 2,000
people in IT right different things
means different different skills mean
different things how you can accomplish
or go about how what type of approach
that you want to take when it comes to
data migration and if you were to look
at it you know the way we look at it
Accenture we have a maturity scale if
you will where it's incremental so
customers look at it and start looking
at okay well one of the first things
that we do we look at data storage type
of migrating to the cloud that's one of
the easiest things that will get your
feet wet as part of the process where
you can start migrating some of these
type of things to the cloud as you start
getting them into the cloud you start
looking at your applications what can I
do within my application type of demint
so that I can leverage this data that I
have just migrated to the cloud as you
start looking into that you start
looking for ways to optimize your data
architecture for new different type of
applications that you basically say well
you know what I'm no longer like the
fact that we're bound by this type of
legacy constraints that we had earlier
so we're trying to react systems that
leverage everything on the cloud that's
what we call born on the cloud type of
things or native type of cloud
applications and as you start gaining
the lessons learned and the experience
our objective is at the end of the day
and it's an incremental one just let me
re-emphasize on that is to get to what
we call the data intelligence on the
cloud right whether that means machine
learning AI or whatever it is you name
it it doesn't matter right I want to
extract that insight from the cloud so
that I have the right consumers I have
the right insides at my fingertip and
that would allow me to impact the
business so that I can operate using new
different business models new revenue
streams because I'm able to consider new
patterns that my data is allowing me to
do and
intelligence is giving me insight such
that I can go and start marketing to a
different segment that I completely
ignored before using that type of
intelligence or before using a machine
learning right new different clusters of
customers are coming up a new way of
discovering new medicines or
interactions between different medical
type of components right so all of these
type of things the objective is to get
to that data supply chain on the cloud
so that we re our Kotak our on-prem type
of data so that it's modernized and
extended to the cloud and at the end of
the day I can create these type of
services that would allow me to go there
and as part of that process basically
you have to go and look at well what can
I do differently to get to that level of
maturity right so it all starts with
capturing so we have different type of
formats different type of data that's
coming along the way from different type
of sources is your existing type of
practices capable of capturing that type
of data and most likely the answer is
not so you have to go and look at that
and assess what's needed in order to get
there once you capture curate put that
with like ten underlines there because
that's one of the premises that would
guarantee you that you will not fall
into that data swamp type of practice
it's one of them but it's a key one when
you start curating your data that means
basically not a single person will come
and say okay well just get that file and
dump it into the data link there would
have to be lots of checks and balances
that basically would say okay why are
you doing that what type of data that
we're getting into what type of data
profiling that needs to be applied what
type of metadata etc etc that needs to
get there right and once you do that I
can enable the consumption of that data
in my type of organization and then I
enable additional things related to
manage and govern because once you get
it there you need to manage it you need
to govern it and that becomes a
continuous cycle and then as new things
happen you need to evolve you don't just
do it once and say okay well I'm done
with it because there is always a new
data format that would come up that may
expedite things that may
do 10x load factor for your data that
could be something that you want to look
into right and then how you can operate
that data and get it into the new ways
of doing things whether that's social
mobile IOT whatever it is that we hear
about all this time as part of the
evolving of technology that we see on a
daily basis now this slide it's not
intended to scare you especially for
those who are on the small and medium
size this slide is really here to show
the level of sophistication and
complexity that is required in order to
get to the right data practices why is
that because you know it's not an
Accenture invention if you look at it I
mean it starts all the way from vision
and mission and creating the right data
strategy for your organization all the
way down to what type of measurements
and then the cross-cutting concerns
around governance management if you are
an SI sitting in this room you come and
say well we have something similar right
and I'm sure a lot of you are doing
something similar to that and I raise it
here just because it's needed you know
whether you implement 100 percent of
that or you implement 50 percent of that
or whatever percentage that you think is
appropriate for your business remember
the three principles we talked about
earlier I have an objective I have a
different way to approach it whether I'm
small and medium versus a large
organization and similarly I look at
this type of methodology and say okay
well what do I need to take out of that
and that becomes a decision point for
your organization so that you look at it
and say okay for my organization I'm
going to do these type of activities or
I'm going to do some of them and I'm
skipping XY and Z and you document that
and there should be a good valid reason
why aren't you doing that right so that
becomes an important thing so that you
are aware at least you give it a thought
okay for my type of situation I don't
need that and here is a looking at it
from agnostic type of perspective you
start looking at your data sources data
staging data ingestion how we are going
to curate the data all of these type of
things are decision points what are you
doing about that
of real-time ingestion for this type of
data formats are you having to deal with
that type of setup or is that something
that's not necessary and if you do have
this type of thing and you're not doing
anything about it
are you losing any type of benefits as a
business from not paying enough
attention to that type of data so let me
switch gears to data migration GCP and I
think that's where the majority of you
are coming here as part of the process
so we covered the methodology and the
key point from ontology is the fact that
it's not a trivial type of endeavor if
you talk to somebody and I have talked
to many customers in the past where they
come to us you know what we'll just move
that data from here the Google cloud in
ten minutes or one hour that's it right
that is the wrong answer yes we can do
that but is that what we want the answer
is no right and for the previous reasons
if that has planted the seed of doubt
when somebody comes talks to you about
this type of proposition I think you
need to be asking these type of
questions will come somebody comes and
says it's an hour type of a job or two
hours or three days or whatever it is
right because the objective is not to
get the data to the cloud the objective
is what can I do with that data what
type of insight what type of governance
that needs to be there right so let's
keep that in mind as we look into data
migration to DCP because I'm going to be
claiming that it's gonna take ten
minutes right because yes it does but
keep that in mind okay so the first
question when it comes to data to GCP is
the question around speed of network and
how much data do you have as part of the
process right so if you're trying to
migrate 10 terabytes or hundred
terabytes of data and you're having a
network speed of 100 megabits per second
you can see that for 10 terabytes I'm
going to take 12 days for 10 megabits
I'm going to take 124 days if you have
if you happen to be on the lucky side of
one gigabyte or thinking about or 100
even it's gonna take much less so the
question will basically need to ask am I
going to do this
on a physical type of manner versus
online and you use this chart basically
to help you to decide if you are happen
to be on this lower corner here most
likely you are going to use a physical
type of approach to move your data from
whatever location into google cloud okay
next question that comes to BS and it's
an important question is if you were to
look at the Google data constructs that
we have out of GCP if you look at it for
the first time it could be overwhelming
right so the next question that
basically need to ask is what type of
data I'm trying to migrate and if you
start from top you can look at it from
two different classification either it's
a structured data or unstructured data
if it's unstructured data it's pretty
much easy if I don't have a need for
mobile SDKs Google Cloud Storage most
likely an object type of storage will be
the answer to you right if you were to
say okay it's more of a structured data
then we look at it from
OLTP versus OLAP type of classification
if it has more of a transactional load
we have a decision point that we need to
make if it has more of analytics type of
load we have the big table versus
bigquery and the primary difference is
in the type of latency that you get in
terms of big big table versus big query
if it's on the transactional workload
then you look at it and say do I have a
preference for SQL type of interfaces
versus no SQL and that's where you look
at it and say okay well for SQL type we
have the cloud SQL with my my sequel and
Postgres as the two flavors that you get
out of the box in GCP plus cloud data
spanner for the horizontal scalability
and real time type of applications that
require that level of performance and
for those who wants to do the new SQL
document type of story have cloud
datastore and firebase real time DB
especially for needing mobile SDKs you
can use that but doesn't necessarily
mean that you cannot use cloud datastore
with mobile devices it just gives you
additional capabilities when it comes
notifications and these type of things
that makes life a little bit easier for
you
the third question that you need to ask
is okay I figured out it's going to
physical or online I figured out what
type of construct that I need to get
then the third question is how can I get
my data into GCP right and that's what
this slide is trying to address here and
look at it from in terms of distance the
GCP at the bottom the x-axis and the
y-axis is the amount of data so from x
axis perspective you look at it if you
are in GCS or Google Cloud Storage the
data is already there on Google cloud
could be in a different region you want
to shift it to another region or it
could be in s3 buckets Amazon or
something else or it could be in a Colo
type of facility with good type of
connectivity or on-prem with that type
of connectivity or it could be somewhere
on Prem with low bandwidth or no
bandwidth at all you are at the sea
right so what do you do with these type
of situations so if you were to look at
it from that perspective we have the
Google transfer service that's part of
the Google console right so you can go
to storage and you can set up the Google
transfer service you can do it run once
run daily so you can think of it if you
want to as a cron job that you can do it
to backup continuously as part of the
process and you can there is no limit on
the amount of data that you can do with
the Google transfer service it can do
retries as well and it can help you with
that perspective if you were to look at
the Colo type of situation or on Prem
with good connectivity then one of the
primary answers we have is yes you till
you get gsutil as part of the cloud SDK
you can install it and you can start
gsutil CP and you can copy from bucket
to bucket or you can copy from one
location to another and it has the
ability to shunt the file into multiple
ones and aggregates them on the end and
does all of that for you it has retries
can do all of that if you don't like
gsutil you have different vendors that
you can use also if you want a an
approach that event that could come in
and do it for you can use bit speed as
parrot dribbler and there are other
vendors as well I put the link later
where you can go and look at the latest
and greatest then the third option if
you don't have enough bandwidth and or
no bandwidth at all so if the data size
is less than hundred terabytes usually
you would get into the Iron Mountain in
North America and there is a prime focus
technologies in
yeah an age a pack and they could still
use the Google transfer appliance right
so these are things that you can do if
the data size goes above 100 terabytes
you can have the Google transfer
appliance where they ship that appliance
to you you put the data and you ship it
back to Google and they'll import it
back to you the right project to the
right buckets in Google Cloud storage
right and the same thing for Zadar azure
daraa also have an option for data
hydration with chips two devices one you
can put the data and ship it back the
other one you can keep it on Prem where
it starts sinking the data for Delta
type of changes down the road now this
is pretty much for the first entry into
Google Cloud practice right Google Cloud
storage now you may have structured data
and structured data is also you can move
it from different type of sources to
different type of things and primarily
for structured data if you looked at the
previous diagram we have two databases
or two constructs one is the Cloud SQL
with my sequel and most Postgres and the
other one is spanner you can if you want
to use the old traditional ways of doing
data dumps compress or dumps from SQL 1
to SQL 2 and you can do that but lots of
customers don't want to do that they
want to migrate or move tons of data and
they'd rather use a portal you can do
that too and you can do the same thing
for bigquery it's also a partner play
where you can have different type of
sources coming from databases SAS data
warehouses or B 2 B II the I type of
stuff and you have all these partners
that are basically having their
different type of solutions catering to
migrating that data to bigquery
if you have and also we have this that
was announced last year that you can
migrate and the ability to ingest data
from double-click the digital marketing
type of platform from Google along with
Adwords and YouTube and you have
additional sources that are listed under
that link for Facebook Twitter etc that
can be part of that process of migrating
data to bigquery now there are other
people who are on the other end of the
spectrum where they have the right
engineering or whatever it is
they would like to tinker with their
hands and Google gives you the ability
to do that so you can use gsutil tool to
do that if you want to so you can get
the data through the acetal to a google
cloud storage and then you can use
either the BQ command if you want to or
you can use the web UI or it can use
bigquery api's to get the data into
bigquery it's just a more type of a more
manual approach that you would have to
be kind of doing that just something to
keep in mind be q tool when you get the
data to bigquery you're basically making
a fundamental assumption you're not
enriching the data or there's very
minimal type of changes that you need to
do on the data right the moment you
start saying I want to do multiple joins
I want to do some data enrichment then
that's where data flow comes into the
picture and I'll talk about that shortly
but that basically is what what this
fundamental premise here you can use
user-defined functions in bigquery to do
certain manipulations but still it's
limited in terms of the enrichment that
you can do on the data set before moving
it to data query bigquery now this slide
I don't recommend that you show that
slide to your customers or anybody
outside of being a techie because it's
overwhelming to be honest with you if
you show that hey by the way I'm going
here to sell you something on Google and
here's what Google offers out of the
table it's complete opposite purpose you
know I should show it here because I
want to show you there are tons of
capabilities and the objective is to be
more prescriptive when you talk to your
customers right yes it's great that we
have a lot of constructs around capture
curate discover manage and consume and
manage but you as a potential partner or
customer you need to figure out what is
the right use case for you what is the
right construct for you and then try to
figure out okay here's what I need to do
it's maybe cloud data prep cloud
dataflow cloud pops up and bigquery
right so these are the ones that I'm
interested in the rest is great to have
I can look into it later but show that
to your customer
from the get-go could be counter
productive now there are customers who
basically say you know what I don't like
this whole thing about the migration so
I want a white glove type of service and
that's where Accenture comes in right
with every vendor you looked at the
vendors in the previous slides there are
so many of them and with so many of them
basically that gives you the freedom to
choose but also gives you the potential
that you may shoot yourself in the foot
because you may be picking the wrong
construct you may be picking the wrong
cloud platform you may be picking the
wrong tool and Accenture basically what
allows you to do in that quite a glove
type of approach with what we call the
smart data movement you just tell us we
want to move from point A to point B and
you don't worry about the rest we go and
procure this type of licenses for the
right tool for you and we do the
migration and all we have to do is just
let us see where the data is coming from
and where it needs to go to and that's
it we take care of that right so that's
part of the construct and we also have
capabilities around different type of
elements when it comes to capture curate
discover consume and manage right so
there are different capabilities they're
not going to go into them but just be
aware that they are available to you
here is the SDM type of approach under
the covers basically we cater to a
different type of cloud providers GCP
happens to be one of them under the
cover the right tools would be procured
licences managed for you and you get to
that so you pretty much agnostic you
don't care about whether it's too late
we'll be that vendor goes out of
business tomorrow or of they're still in
business it doesn't matter right we just
give you the guarantee that they will be
there you're not locked in to any
specific vendor and that does the job
for you so let's talk about path to
machine learning and AI so machine
learning and and and the use cases I
doubt there has been any session today
who are machine learning probably was
not mentioned somewhere in that session
right we are at that level of hype cycle
that and won't get me wrong I love
machine learning I mean I think it's a
wonderful technology right but it's
with everything else like we have done
in IT when we start looking at something
and overhype it and we start looking
it's the answer to every question that
we have that's where the problems start
arising right and I think we are at that
level where everybody says and comes
talk to us oh I want to apply machine
learning to my X Y Z and I bet you that
many of those type of customers they
don't have the right awareness on what
is meant by machine learning and if that
is the right set of tools or processes
that would allow them to address the
problem but as you can see there are
lots of use cases that are listed here
across different type of industries that
basically you know everybody is looking
at saying okay well predictive
maintenance or condition monitoring
right we've done that with a predictive
model in the past right things were okay
probably 80% 90% accuracy now with
machine learning additional constructs
that are happening you can get to higher
levels of accuracy right so Google
basically says we have elements of
machine learning in every product that
we have that's great that's Google right
but the majority of customers out there
they're not Google so you have to be
very careful when it comes to machine
learning and say okay well am i
addressing the right set of questions
am I having the right use cases as part
of machine learning and is the right
thing for me to do as part of the
organization and if you look at at the
transforming data into actions you know
Google provides different type of
constants when it comes from data
ingestion all the way down to advanced
analytics and machine learning and
abilities to do that right so and and
this type of steps would be required if
you attended the Miles Ward session the
first thing that we do in machine
learning I have to get the data into GCP
right somewhere I need to get the data
and and start building applications and
that generates additional data then you
start applying machine learning right so
these are key and that's part of what
what the the ecosystem that Google
provides in order to give you that
ability to ingest the data all the way
up to creating that advanced analytics
and intelligence and apply machine
learning on to it
and if you are interested in what type
of constructs that you are looking into
here's the diagram again I wouldn't go
and talk to my customer and say okay
here look what how Google is great and
all that because that basically tells
complexity so we want to be more
prescriptive as part of the process and
figure out what type of things that we
need to do in order to get to that level
of complexity so if you were to get data
into GCP right here are some of the
things that usually that we see as big
data reference architecture right so
typical components these are the typical
suspects I have two types of workloads
one could be potential streaming
workload the other one is a batch
workload and the objective is to get it
somewhere into bigquery or BigTable or
whatever it is right and usually we look
into it and say okay well for pub/sub
type of streaming we have a cloud
pub/sub that we want to incorporate as
part of the the architecture and then I
could take that stream and let it feed
through data flow because I want to do
certain manipulations I could do certain
enrichments on it whatever I want to do
and then I can have a resting-place in
bigquery so that would be one path to
look into it
you can take a batch load you can put
that batch road in Google Cloud Storage
the GCS component right and you can take
that batch load and say okay well I want
to apply certain enrichments on it as
part of the process and then for this
particular load the data could be more
appropriate for being stored as part of
Google BigTable because I am very
concerned about latency and BigTable
gives you that type of access to it or
you can say I would like to apply
certain data product type of
capabilities manipulations and then
store the data in cloud BigTable you
still have the option if you wanted to
store data in cloud data proc right you
can use data proc HDFS on SSD or
persistent disks but that's not
necessarily a good approach because it's
more expensive to store that data in
data proc right the the best practice is
to have the data store in GCS and allow
data proc to run clusters that would
basically figure out what would be the
right destination for that data so this
is pretty much the end-to-end way of
looking at a big data reference
architecture by allowing you to get a
streaming load or a batch work load to
get the data into TCP and then you have
on the far right end is the ability for
any type of data for the data
exploration machine learning type of
activities analytics dashboards whatever
it is that you can start looking and
applying on these type of data sets that
you have stored as part of bigquery you
know let's dissect that piece by piece
and look at it and say well you know
what I have a streaming blowed I just
want to get it directly to bigquery can
I do that the answer is yes you can
there's nothing that says you can't with
the assumption that you're not
manipulating the data I talked about
that earlier right so you can get a
streaming workload or a batch workload
and put it directly and for bigquery and
you can do simple manipulations on the
BQ command and data we get into bigquery
if you want to go and say okay well I
have a batch workload this is the I
would like to go and and put that into
my Google Cloud Storage I would like to
do some type of enrichment on that type
of workload and then I want to bet batch
that pipeline into a bigquery and that's
also another option that's available to
you and then this one is I have an
on-prem type of data that I parked on
Prem through an ETL job now I need to
move it it's a relational so I need to
move it to cloud SQL into GCP and then I
take that data from cloud SQL and I can
run it through my data pipeline again
against cloud dataflow do some
additional enrichment joins or whatever
it is that you want to do with it and
then feed it
to bigquery that also a pattern that we
see out there or you can have a fan in
fan out type of multiple streaming type
of clients that you want to get the data
and as part of getting that data you
want to do a different type of
processing for that data and you have
different instances of bigquery where
you have instance a of bigquery and
instance B of bigquery and you can have
the right job being streamed to the
right channel that becomes the ending
resting place for bigquery and you can
have also additional type of
manipulations where you can stream and
compute before you publish so I stream
my data from a financial type of company
or organization and as part of the
process the data gets into cloud pops up
and then I do certain manipulations on
the data certain enrichments
calculations and then I add additional
type of windowing or do time type of
series calculations and then I calculate
certain correlations and then feed that
again to a cloud pops up or I have
multiple subscribers where I'm trying to
figure out how the stock market is going
to do or how certain stocks are going to
behave under certain type of situation
or conditions and I can feed that into a
trading system where there could be
people who are waiting or acting on this
type of intelligence or I could feed
that back into bigquery where I can
apply certain dashboarding analytics
machine learning whatever it is that I
want to do and I can start the exploring
good cloud data lab as part of the
process so what this is trying to show
you you know the suspects that you have
seen they're very common right so we
talked about pub/sub dataflow bigquery
BigTable and and detail app as part of
the top components that are usually
involved in GCS obviously right these
are the the primary ones the primary
ones that are involved as part of the
process of getting data into GCP and
here's an example
interesting okay so here's an example
where basically shows I have an existing
data leak that's installed on Prime and
as part of that process I have different
type of source data sources and I need
to feed that data into a Google type
okay so so I have different type of
constructs that I want to incorporate so
I have the GCSE connector where
basically I can push the data directly
to GCSE because GCSE it's Hadoop
compliant type of file storage system
so using that GCSE connector I can use
the push model where I can push the data
directly to GCSE or I can aggregate the
data do some type of enrichment on it
and I can use a partner happens to be
informatica or anything it doesn't
matter and I can use that to push the
data to GCP and then I can feed that
into my pipeline of cloud dataflow or
cloud data prep which is also allows you
to do some additional data profiling as
part of the process and then you can
have the option to move the data into
cleanse data as part of the storage and
and this is basically ingesting into a
data Lake and as I mentioned earlier as
part of the data Lake we try to avoid
storing stuff in in data proc so the alt
the the preferred method is to use this
the cheaper storage of GCS and if you
happen if your workload happens to be
more appropriate for BigTable sure why
not you can do that and in many
instances you will see that people will
go against bigquery to store the data
and use data proc ephemeral clusters
basically to run certain jobs and sort
the data in the right thrusting
locations and you can apply the
visualization on that as part of the
process and this gets us to the machine
learning lifecycle right so the machine
learning lifecycle you know if you
attended miles Ward you probably have
seen this diagram I did not have it and
I recreated it for this session so I'll
give credit to that so
so this basically defy the first thing
that you need to do as part of any
machine learning is to look at the use
cases and I alluded to that earlier in
the session that becomes a really
important type of factor to make sure
that you are addressing the right ones
and defining the successor criteria that
you want to do then we get into data
exploration basically I want to do
exploratory data analysis and you can
use any type of clustering type of
mechanisms I'm trying to reduce the
amount of parameters that I want to
build the model from and I can go and
select what type of machine learning
algorithm and I can do later further
feature engineering which basically
looks into additional type of criteria
and and selecting the right parameters
for the right model and you build your
first iteration of the machine learning
model and you iterate on that with you
know kind of building your Minimum
Viable type of model right and once you
do that you basically look at it and say
okay well are there things that we can
change or improve as part of the process
and then you start presenting results
that yeah okay well you told us that we
can challenge the current supply chain
model that you have in order to give you
better accuracy and cheaper way to get
these data parts coming to the u.s.
through different vendors and routes and
here's the model who would allow us to
do that right so let's look at these
results and see if there is any value in
to them or if the older model is a
better type of performing model and then
you start planning for deployment in
production and that's where you start
getting into interesting type of setups
right so what type of production what
type of clusters what type of data
ingestion how busy are the machines
going to be are they going to busy all
the time are you going to stream the
data is it bad etc are you going to run
this at the same time while other data
is coming so all these are type of
questions and usually what we do we
start with a POC
a simple POC that doesn't factor any of
this into it and people think that once
they've done the PRC a lot of the
legwork has been done and you get into
the previous pattern we talked about
with data leaks it's not there's a lot
of consideration that needs to be taken
from seven through ten to make sure that
you know we have the right model
we monitor them they are the right ones
the most efficient and sometimes there
could be some performance issues that
could rise in the future so what do you
do about those do you go and rebuild the
model and you repeat the cycle
right so the whole process is iterative
and lots of complexities in the details
here it's not just building a PLC in six
weeks and we're done with that so and
you've seen this probably before if
you've been to many of the sessions you
can use your own rebuilt ready to use
models you know there is no point for
you to go and create a model that can go
and recognize objects right we're
talking two different companies right
now to build solutions around these
things you know I can look at satellite
images I can look at third-party data
weather data and look at natural
language processing translate API is to
come up with a solution that would give
them a better score when it comes to
underwriting processes for insurance
right so these are things that you can
put together as part of the process you
can build a model that takes elements of
these type of factors and and
incorporate that into a model that can
give you a better result than what you
may be having today and you can use your
own data to train these models you know
you feel free to build your own models
using tensorflow and feel free to upload
them to Google cloud let them run in the
cloud and see what type of results that
you can get out of that and and empower
your business to be the right business I
have one minute left I want to spend on
this client example I talked mostly
about what this thing is all about but
this is a customer the pattern that
we're seeing you know they were running
cloud era
on prem using and spending a lot of
money really that was the primary driver
for they were basically spending about
20k per month on their cloud era type of
setup and they came to us and said well
we would like to move that to GCP right
so if you look at the architecture this
is what they have as part of this so
they have cloud era running on GCP in in
in VMs type of formats and the solution
was basically to
them to the right set up using data proc
and ephemeral clusters and using Google
Cloud storage as part of the process the
previous session I was here in the last
10-15 minutes the gentleman was citing
different statistics about moving the
Hadoop infrastructures at the data proc
he was citing 70 percent savings on
Hardware 80 percent or more on software
we saved this company from 20,000 down
to 4,000 per month and it's about 80
percent savings so I'm glad we have the
consistency in this type of settings as
part of you know the savings that you
can get from migrating this existing
Hadoop workloads from on-prem or using
VMs on GCP sometimes people think I'm
using VM on GCP for cloud there I'm
still on the cloud no you're not well
you are but it's not the most efficient
way to do it right there are better ways
to do it and this is one one of those
things that you can use as part of that
process
[Music]